احرم مني من عرسي احرم مني من شبابي احرم
مني من كل شيء
وبدا ذاك اليوم الذي استعدت فيه الشابه
دليله لتكون العروس بيوم مشؤوم في تاريخها
لقد بتر القدم بلغم حوثي وعدل العريس عن
قرار الزواج قرار تقول الفتى احال حياتها
الى جحيم
كثير لمى
[موسيقى]
للخزنه جبنه
الاول به اللعبه
الثانيه
معور الرجل السلام معود
المال كله
بؤس الحياه لاكثر من 360 امراه يمنيه في
تعز وصبنا بعبوات والغم
منهن في منطقه الشقب وحدها جنوبي المدينه
ملانا الالغام بتبيض وتعمل لنا الالغام
جميع الحاجات ده الوديان المزارع بكل شيء
نحن مبرر من الحودين اني اهلي اربعاء الذي
هم تواجه نحن ثلاث مبطلات اسره واحده
ثانيه ثانيه
النساء والاطفال فالمنازل في قرى الشرقيه
يقول الاهالي نسفت بعبوات المليشيات اما
عقاراتهم وممتلكاتهم صارت منهوبه بايدي
قيادات حوثيه على مدى ثمانيه اعوام من
الحرب
السكنيه سيما في منطقه الشعب جنوبي تعز
بعضها كانت بالالغام والعبوات الناسفه
وبعضها رميه بالرصاص ال سعيد العربيه
تعز